The template property now holds
the result of compiling the template.
Which means that this is a function and
now it's just waiting to
be called with some data.
That happens right here, so
let's add a break point and
refresh the page to see how it works.
The template function is called
with the model's attributes.
We can step into this function call
by clicking on this button here.
This takes us back to underscore, back
to the function that we just build up.
Data is the information for
the menu item.
Remember that render is
the function that we've built up in
the previous video.
The render function is called and
the model's data is passed to it.
Let's step in to render and
see what's going on.
We are now inside the function that was
constructed from the HTML template.
It looks a little complicated but
here's the start of the TD and
here is its closing tag.
The content of the TD will be an empty
string if the property is missing, or
it will be the property itself.
So these lines all form one big string
and are stored in p, then p is returned.
We can check p on the console
to see what is being returned or
we can see what this
function returns over here.
Returning from this function
takes us back to template and
from here we go back to App dot JS.
Finally after its long arduous journey
the template that's now populated with
data is inserted into this element.
Wow, all of that to compile and render
a template, before we leave underscore,
I need to mention one more
thing about variables and
the way they're referenced in templates.